hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Horror
Supernatural film called flight 7500 or
flight
7500 or flight 7500 it's a dumb name
have it however you like spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie revolves around the passengers
of Vista Pacific Airlines flight 7500
which is traveling from Los Angeles to
Tokyo in the first scene the plane
suddenly loses control with the Tokyo
Air Traffic Control causing chaos
amongst the passengers however one woman
is unusually calm and she says that
death is part of life so we must accept
it and not waste a single second of it a
series of images then flashes on the
screen depicting what appears to be the
plane going through turbulence and the
passengers screaming as they brace for
impact following this the movie flashes
back to four hours earlier before it all
went wrong piloted by Pete haining the
plane is about to take off under clear
weather conditions meanwhile two flight
attendants Laura and Susie are making
the necessary preparations for takeoff
one by one the passengers also start to
board they include a vacationing couple
broad I mean and Pia a thief named Jake
Lance Morel a suspicious businessman
traveling with a strange wooden box
newlyweds Rick and Liz and and a goth
jacinta she has no defining
characteristics she is just a goth Lance
the businessman appears overly
protective of the box and keeps it in
the storage located underneath his seat
meanwhile it is revealed that flight
attendant Laura is in a secret
relationship with the married Captain
Pete as the passengers settle down the
two make out secretly the mile high club
is this dude's office Laura informs him
that the ground control is relayed an
Urgent Message about an important check
having been overlooked however Pete
brushes it aside and continues to fool
around with her the only thing being
overlooked is my erection Laura on the
other hand Brad Pia and another couple
are the only passengers in the business
class it turns out they had been
planning and saving for this once in a
lifetime trip for years Brad and Pia
have secretly broken up but they have
kept the news from their friends to
prevent the plan from getting spoiled
meanwhile Liz is on a honeymoon with her
husband Rick snob by Nature she prays
that no one sits beside her so she can
be alone with him in the row however
jacinta suddenly shows up and takes the
seat Liz stares at her for a while and
it appears as if she is troubled by The
Goth aesthetic she then notices the
empty seat behind them and asks Jacinto
if she would consider moving but the
latter politely declines as the two
ladies talk it becomes clear that Rick
is intrigued by jacinta's persona but he
quickly turns around when his wife
catches him staring at the strangers
ripped jeans shortly after the pilots
announced that they are about to take
off so the flight attendants check on
all the passengers carefully when Laura
approaches the suspicious looking Lance
she asks him to put his box in the
overhead compartment the latter obliges
but it's evident that he is hiding
something very important inside of it
soon the plane takes off and the
passengers are finally allowed to take
off their seat belts the thief Jake
tries to strike a conversation with a
woman seated next to him but she only
gives him cold responses she also
notices multiple phones in his bag and
figures out that he is a thief in the
next scene the plane hits unexpected
turbulence so all the passengers fasten
their seat belts and nervously wait for
it to pass after after a few intense
minutes the situation reverts back to
normal and everyone breathes a sigh of
relief however Lance suddenly
experiences a panic attack and struggles
to breathe when his health continues to
deteriorate the flight attendants
request any doctor or medical
professional on board to come forward
unfortunately before they can come up
with a diagnosis Lance begins to bleed
profusely from his mouth soon Brad comes
forward and reveals that he is a
paramedic thank God that's lucky Rick
also volunteers to help and they try to
save Lance but the businessman suddenly
starts convulsing at this point all the
passengers are only staring at Lance
encouraging him to pull through however
right in front of their eyes heat stops
moving and breathing all together Rick
and Brad try to revive him by
administering CPR but to no avail get
Laura to make out with him that seems to
work for the pilot despite the
devastating incident Captain Pete
decides to continue their journey to
Japan the crew then moves all the first
class passengers into economy making
room for Lance's lifeless body meanwhile
Liz is not happy with her husband giving
CPR to Lance she complains that he
probably has the dead man's blood on his
lips jacinta overhears the conversation
and says the death is a part of life and
as the airplane crew moves Lance's body
she touches his hands and creepily
admires his blood shortly after Liz goes
to the washroom and Rick uses the
opportunity to strike up a conversation
with jacinta he compliments her way of
thinking and reveals that he too isn't
afraid of death in reply jacinta says
that if everyone knew when they were
going to die they wouldn't waste a
single second of whatever time they had
left this impresses Rick you're right we
should bone uh what did you say but as
he is about to spice up their
conversation Liz returns and interrupts
them later while dispensing drinks Laura
notices Lance's bloody tooth in his seat
and starts seeing flashbacks of him
convulsing when the Visions get out of
hand she panics and eventually falls to
the ground suddenly the plastic water
bottles start collapsing and it turns
out that the cabin pressure is dropping
Brad's Nails also start to turn blue
indicating that the situation is only
about to become worse soon the plane
starts to Free Fall causing Mayhem among
the passengers after a lot of struggle
the pilots somehow managed to stabilize
the plane but it continues to shake
violently to make matters worse the
carbon dioxide levels start Rising so
oxygen masks are dispensed above the
seats however Pia's Mask doesn't work
forcing Brad to give up his oxygen and
find himself another one he then notices
a child unconscious in another row and
goes over to help her meanwhile a woman
named Raquel is stuck in a bathroom
without oxygen she somehow manages to
open but before she can put on a mask
she passes out as the devastation
continues Brad notices that pia has
fainted so he returns to his seat and
tries to wake her up fortunately after
holding his oxygen mask against her
mouth for a few seconds she regains
Consciousness the situation inside the
plane also returns to normal and Captain
Pete reveals that the cabin
depressurized because a seal was damaged
due to the previous turbulence the issue
is now been isolated and the plane is
flying at a lower altitude hearing this
everyone finally removes their oxygen
masks and breathes a sigh of relief
elsewhere as Laura is checking up on all
the passengers one by one she notices
Raquel passed out in the washroom the
poor woman is immediately given
emergency oxygen and after a few seconds
she wakes up meanwhile Pia notices a
reflection of a frightening ghostly
Apparition but when she turns around
there's nothing it's almost as if she
has started going paranoid because of
the circumstances around her on the
other hand the thief Jake leaves his
seat and covertly sneaks into the
business class it turns out he has his
eyes set on Lance's Rolex Watch the
watch says it's time for stealing after
getting the job done he even takes a
selfie with the dead man but right then
Lance starts to move freaking the hell
out of Jake when the latter pulls back
the cloth covering the body he is left
in utter disbelief he falls on his back
and starts crawling but the Unseen Force
eventually gets to him in the cockpit
Captain Pete tries to establish contact
with the Tokyo radio but he only hears a
distorted voice on the other end of the
line Brad starts watching The Twilight
Zone an in-flight TV show to take his
mind off everything around him however
his screen starts to distort and he sees
an image of a lance an hour later the
flight attendant Laura notices strange
lights outside the plane window but she
brushes it off as Her Imagination she
then realizes that Jake is missing from
his seat so she goes over to ask Raquel
about his whereabouts when the latter
reveals that he went to the first class
Laura and her fellow attendant Susie
head there to inspect surprisingly not
only is Jake missing but Lance's body is
also not there creeped out by what they
just saw the two immediately rushed back
to economy class Laura then informs the
captain about the missing passenger in
the dead body she also tells him about
the strange light she saw outside the
window earlier suspecting it to be an
F-16 fighter jet however Pete quickly
rebuffs her claims saying that no
fighter jets have come anywhere near his
radar since they took off on the other
hand Raquel again goes to the bathroom
for some important work turns out she's
been trying to conduct a pregnancy test
to her relief the test comes out
negative however before she could leave
smoke begins to fill the toilet and a
strange hand grabs her and pulls her
into the floor in the next scene the
flight attendant's Laura and Susie
perform a sweep row by row looking for
Lance's body when broad learns of this
he reveals that he saw Lance's image on
his screen earlier Pia also admits to
seeing something similar which proves
that they are not hallucinating hence
with the help of the other couple Rick
and Liz they decide to find out more
about Lance for the first step they
bring out his carry-on luggage and take
it to the gallery on opening it the
group finds multiple tubes of hair with
women's names taped onto them soon The
Goth jacinta also learns about the
group's private investigation so she
retrieves Lance's wooden box and gives
it to them she then returns to her seat
and tries to sleep but an unknown force
keeps pulling her blanket down after a
while the two flight attendants catch
Brad in the group trying to break into
Lance's wooden box Laura tells them that
they can't touch his personal property
but Rick explains that strange things
have been happening on this plane ever
since Lance died so they just want to
investigate Rick also suggests going
through Lance's check the luggage in the
cargo hold but Laura turns down that
idea and sends them back to their
respective seats however after taking a
good look at Lance's belongings Laura
changes her mind she then goes to the
cargo hold to search for his checked
luggage while Susie Waits outside
unfortunately there a hand suddenly
emerges and drags Laura away meanwhile
Brad and the others return with jacinta
to continue their investigation when
they open Lance's wooden box they find a
death doll jacinta being a hardcore nerd
seems to know about this she explains
that the doll is a Shinigami in Japanese
mythology Shinigami is a death spirit
that collects people's Souls after they
die but only if they let go of what is
holding them to this world as jacinta
continues explaining the mythology the
doll suddenly starts to make strange
noises this makes the group realize that
Lance is perhaps refusing to let go of
his soul or his watch meanwhile Captain
Pete starts hearing distorted noise on
the radio suddenly someone appears from
behind and he screams out of fear
elsewhere as Susie waits for Laura by
the cargo hold hatch another hand tries
to pull her down Susie somehow escapes
its clutches and runs into first class
but a mysterious cloud of smoke follows
her the smoke quickly clears and Brad
Pia Rickles and jacinta rushed to find
out what is wrong as Susie walks towards
them one of the overhead compartments
opens and Shia is sucked into it
panicking everyone rushes downstairs
towards the cockpit while jacinta hears
her own words and hesitantly walks
towards an unknown figure which appears
before her the others discover Captain
Pete and the co-pilot dead in their
seats even Raquel is seen lifeless
inside the bathroom guess she was
pregnant after all with a ghost
realizing that the Unseen Force has
started taking more lives the group
hurries back to their cabin but what
they see there shocks them to the core
everyone including Brad and Rick are
lying dead in their respective seats
just then the TV and the cabin turns on
and it reports that flight 7500 suffered
a catastrophic decompression and all
communication with it has been lost when
a fighter jet was sent to investigate
the plane was revealed to be flying on
autopilot mode and no sign of life was
found on board with this it is finally
revealed that everyone on board has
already died they simply came back as
souls and continued staying on the plane
unaware of the actual truth in reality
all the passengers had died the moment
the plane ran out of oxygen everything
after that was just the mysterious doll
controlling their souls moreover the
strange lights that Laura saw outside
the plane were of the fighter jet that
was sent to investigate after realizing
the entire truth Brad and Pia accept
their death and hug each other one last
time as the plane runs out of fuel and
crashes into the ocean the movie ends as
Liz awakens to find the plane empty she
hears a strange noise coming from a
garbage bin when she inspects a
discolored hand suddenly appears causing
her to scream in horror subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching